hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from the 0/3 chess
festival this is around 6 in my previous
video you have seen how chucky
demolishes tall bar on with the white
pieces this is a round played after that
game unfortunately there is no interview
after this game neither with Avantika or
with jaundice and upon sand upon is an
indian grandmaster he's been a
grandmaster since 2003 and he was also
Vishwanath on Allen's second in his
World Chess Championship match in 2013
against Magnus Carlsen
so quite a strong player and here he has
what the white pieces against divine
choke probably neither of them were
interested in giving an interview I've
checked the trade wise Gibraltar YouTube
channel there is no interview with
either of them it's a shame but the game
is also interesting the game reminds me
in in one in a lot of ways of the famous
game brunch time versus night or I will
put a link to that game in the
description below as it's a pretty same
theme but you'll see what I mean
so sandy pan has the white pieces and he
opens with the d4 Knight to f6 and c4
after beating tal Barone in the previous
round Avenger said that he is looking
he's a very much looking forward to
facing a stronger opponent in the next
round so we'll see if his wish will be
fulfilled east sex by van rook and
Knight to c3 and the Bishop to b4
Chuckie goes for the nimzo-indian
defense III this is the mainline c5 this
is the Huebner
variation Knight to e2 seek after some d
4e captors on d4 and d5 now by Van
choker c5 we have Knight to e4 pinning
that attacking the pin piece Bishop to
d2 defending event captures Queen
captures and here we have a 5 a 3 you
might have
captures on c3 Knight captures on c3 and
now here event you has a couple of
options he can go Bishop d7 he can go b6
to try and undermine this c5 d4
structure Sandip and created in the
center
but again event who goes for the most
active idea he plays a for this prevents
wife from pushing before and also it's a
very annoying pawn next probably much
will go be six Bishop to d7 and maybe
maybe Castle if if you know the
situation on the Queen side won't get
out of hand but here
Sandip on also has a couple of very nice
options he can go Bishop to d3
developing in gonna I'd be five you can
go Roxy won a lot of ideas here but he
plays a move that when I saw it I
immediately thought this is just this is
just bad this must be losing but he
played Knight captures on a four and
what do you make of this move I mean of
course rook captures Bishop b5 check but
then Bishop blocks and I mean Sunday pan
will will give up two pieces for a rock
in the pond so III thought this can't be
good rook captures by a bunch of we have
Bishop to b5 check Bishop blocks Bishop
captures Bishop captures and as you see
if I took one two pieces for a rookie
and the point here we have Kunta P for
attacking the bishop on a for Queen to
d7 and Sundeep and castles here and this
was a good opportunity for event you to
castle as well he could have castled
here for example and after b3 Bishop to
b5 attacking the rook and f1 after the
rook moves Bishop to d3 from here the
bishop will be very strong very
influential he could you know he much
would decide what to do with this Bishop
but it wouldn't be it would be possible
to stop all of these pawns another
problem there but after this castles
event who goes for Queen to b5 and here
he allows this b3 move what happens now
is event captures the Queen we have a
capture some before and here if I took
has to decide whether he will capture
the b3 pawn or will he
retrieve with the bishop if he captures
the b3 pawn
then comes rook to be one Bishop moves
and
now b5 and it's very hard to develop
this night let's say Bishop d3 rock
moves now King three seven trying to
bring the rook into the game but now
rook to a7 is coming and it's again very
hard to find a move here for revenge
Knight to d7 c6 is coming and white is
simply better if you capture then white
wins back the piece but again it's it's
obvious that at one point if I would
have to give up a piece to stop those
pawns but after a character some before
I want to place Bishop to b5 and this is
better you don't want to grab that be
doubled b3 porn better to move the
bishop while attacking the rook here we
have rook to a 7 and this is the main
idea if you play something like rook to
e1 rook to d1 trying to defend this rook
then if you find took manages to play
King to d7 King to c6 there is really
nothing more white can do here these
pawns are stopped there is no more pawn
storm so rook to a7 immediately that b7
point is much more important than
capturing saving the rook on f1 event
you captures the rook we have rook
captures on b7 now threatening to
capture the knight Knight to c6 and here
King captures on f1 and this is why I
said that it reminds me of the famous
branch line I drove game I will put it
in the description below so we can check
it out I made a video about that game
some couple of months ago and I will
also put it in the end screen so you can
simply click on it if you're interested
because here it's pretty much an equal
position but like in the brush and
neither of game neither had it had the
option of either castling or leaving the
King in the center and here for some
reason if I thought that it was actually
okay to castle here event castle and
from there
pretty much everything went downhill a
move he should have played was ripped to
f8 defending the f7 pawn and now the
king is the king is allowed to come into
the game for example b5 now you can
either capture on d4 you have b6 the
pawns
going forward but now you play King to
d8r up to a seven now let's say knight
c6 rocket exit Knight to b3 you do get
c6 but now comes let's say g5 kingi to
h5 we have king to d2 and now Knight
captures on c6 here it's very hard for
either side to make progress so wife can
never push b7 and you want you can
either maybe decide to push f v e5 maybe
push some pawns or he can decide to
immediately go for a draw but definitely
it's not white that can decide anything
so probably after you capture it rook
captures and king here let's say a
couple of moves are played after rook to
b8 you do have doubled be pawns and you
simply can't make any progress here for
white
so after this King to have one capturing
the Speas event took castle instead of
playing rook to f8 here B Phi was played
you have Knight to a5 and here rope to
c7 and it was in this position that
event should resign the game as he saw
that the pawn storm will be too much for
him to handle one variation that we
might check let's say Knight capture
some b3 now b6g six making some
breathing space for a king
b7 or now Knight to a5 as the threat was
roped to c8 now if rope to c8 night
simply captures on b7 but now you get c6
and after king moves let's say rock the
c8 and now the threat is of course
capturing the rook also promoting to a
queen so here black must give up the
night capturing and c6 also protecting
the queening square wife will grab this
and after rook to b8 simply rook to c7
here king f king f6 but now after king
e2 and a couple of more moves you will
see that there is no way for the black
for the black king to approach the
position if v is covered by the pawn on
d4 discovered by the rook and the King
can never
the last rank because Roxy check wins
the game so it's very hard for black to
play this his the material is equal but
the b7 point is simply too powerful
if black wants to make any progress he
will probably have to push a 5 but then
after D capture skin captures rocket
rows on f7 he has to give up a pawn to
try and get back into the game but it
doesn't work kink the d4 and even if
black manages to win the b7 pawn we're
pointing to c6 white will happily
exchange and then the white king will
pick up all of these pawns and win the
game so yeah after this captures castles
b5 Knight to a5 and rook to c7
eventually resigned to the game and a
very nice victory for the Indian Grand
Master Jean de Santa pan I mean when I
saw that Knight captures on a4 I was
like this is just this is just insane
this this can't work but as you can see
it does work and it also worked for
Bronstein in his famous game against
Knight or which I encourage you to check
it out so that's the game from round 6
of trade YC brought our chess festival I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank William Avery
thank you for your constant
contributions to my channel I would like
to thank Thomas Mason oddish Mehta thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here the top one will be
from the famous branch that matter of
game thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon probably with another
game from the Geralt our trade wise
chess festival and also I think I'm all
set with my twitch channel so I will do
a test stream very soon after uploading
this video so thank you all and I will
see you soon